on the talk with us now about what took
place down at the combine is Sirius XM
NFL radios Alex Marvis and in Alex it
was Kyla Marie show before he got there
he weighed in he got his height at five
ten and an eighth he didn't participate
in the on-field drills but yet it still
been the caller Marie show even though
he didn't actually put on a show exactly
how bizarre right and said waiting for
his pro day to compete on March 13th and
this one is just it's very odd to me
first I just for the life of me and I
and listen mark Dominic one of my Sirius
XM partners former Bucs GM he said it
was huge huge that officially Kyler
Marie is five foot ten a shade over five
foot ten so will he was five nine seven
eight does he become chopped liver 592
five nine and 1516 suddenly this is
draft stock fallen does he become a
third-round pick I don't really get that
I do like the fact that his hand size
measured over nine inches which is the
minimum standard by most NFL teams
because quarterbacks need to be able to
control the football and get larger hand
you have the easier it is to do that but
I you know the whole thing to me is so
stranger what's strange to me to now
it's almost like boom or bust like we
have a couple of teams that we see okay
look the Arizona Cardinals yeah maybe
they're after Kyler Murray right because
Josh Rosen yeah there wasn't a very good
work a year and we don't know what went
on behind the scenes and out there
impressed with this young man or not the
Oakland Raiders you know Jon Gruden on
my show says he's not getting past four
what does I mean that the Raiders if
he's available at four are taking Kyle
or Maury and they'll try to trade Derek
Carr is sort of an odd one there but
other than that Kirk what's weird is
who's on the quarterback horizon like
the New York Giants are not exactly
chomping at the bit it appears for Kyle
Omari it appears they want maybe a
larger size quarterback you know maybe
they're fooling us and they're just
keeping their cards close to the vest
but the Jacksonville Jaguars they maybe
go in the nick foles route by all
accounts would they really be in the
market for calimary a quarterback with a
different type skillset that would Nick
Foles brings to the table and the Miami
Dolphins at 13 they need all the
traffic's they can get would they even
have to move up to get Tyler Murray it's
just a very straight thing what's
happened did this drafted I guess Connor
Murray himself is emblematic of it you
know Alex one of the questions that you
can always present when you try to
look at where Colin Murray is as you
kind of try to compare him to last
year's first first round crop of
quarterbacks where there was Baker
Mayfield Sam d'Arnaud Josh Allen Josh
Rosen or Lamar Jackson
if those quarterbacks were in this draft
or if caliber was available in last
year's draft where would Tyler Murray
fall in european-- with those
quarterbacks oh it's such a tough
question and I'm not trying to dodge it
but I'll tell you why we had no body of
Cuyler Murray there's no body of work I
mean the only thing we could do is
compare him to the guy he replaced at
Oklahoma Baker Mayfield right right and
there was no drop-off there at OU you
you know they got to the college
championship game the guy won the
Heisman Trophy he was absolutely
brilliant and all the talk about height
while Baker Mayfield disproved that he's
over six feet tall but Tyler Murray only
had five passes batted down the entire
season I mean through a whole heck of a
lot including a lot of passes from the
pocket you know if there's any analyst
from these other guys coming in I think
the one team that may have buyer's
remorse the Arizona Cardinals and you
know when you talk about coming up with
a plan for your quarterback and to try
to develop one the Cardinals failed
miserably from their decision you know
whether it was Steve wokes convincing
them that that he could develop a
quarterback and then having Mike McCoy
as his offensive coordinator then firing
McCoy just a month into the season and
putting in Byron Leftwich whose offense
didn't exactly bring out the best in
Josh Rosen either to failing to surround
him with quality skill position people
or a good offensive line see I don't
know if Josh Rosen is any good or not
but I will tell you out of all those
other I don't think any other team is
saying wow we really regret drafting our
quarterback from 2018 except potentially
the Arizona Cardinals but I do want to
say this as well if you're the Cardinals
why not keep the rumors out there as far
as your interest in Kyler Murray if you
think you can move down from the number
one pick accumulate draft selections
which the Cardinals have a roster that
has a lot of holes to be filled and you
feel you could still get a quality
defensive lineman in a draft that's rich
in them if you don't drop down too far
then I think that it makes sense to play
this game out a little bit and not and
you know say what you will try to give
Josh Rosen enough of a public vote of
confidence moving ahead that he should
feel good about himself but still trying
to stir up that bad talk - Wow the
Cardinals they really take this guy if
we want
calimary we better be able to give up
some Drive equity to go get him Alex
more vezo series XM NFL radio joining
the Rich Eisen show Kirk Morrison
filling in for Rich but the other
quarterback Dwayne Haskins did go out
and he did perform at the combine now we
know he is not a runner when you look at
that time he had a 540 yard there so we
know he's not a runner but he's a pure
pocket passer did Dwayne Haskins hurt or
helped himself at this combine you know
it'll be interesting to see him run at
his pro day because the media narrative
out there from NFL Network was that he
had a suffered leg cramps right and as
he was cramping and that led to you know
that the 40 time that was you know from
a Sun Dial
so I get it they didn't even need to use
the laser you know what I mean just
counting on their fingers to get him
across the 40 line compared to some of
the other guys in this but he threw just
fine I mean it's really it's Murray and
him and then I think drew Locke is
really steps into the number three
quarterback spot and listen as a Florida
Gator sitting in the end zone as he
carved up my team with his Missouri
Tigers during the season I can tell you
what drew Locke is odd he is pretty darn
good so I think at that point you've got
your top three quarterbacks and then you
start getting into the other guys the
Daniel Jones's the will careers but now
I'm starting to wonder if you know it
was such a little buzz around these guys
might would Tyler Murray being in this
draft might we just have three
quarterbacks taken in round one or
potentially a fourth maybe going at the
end of the round to a team that trades
up or dare I say if the Chargers are New
England Patriots teams are maybe in
position to draft their quarterback of
the future not knowing exactly what that
future is going to begin because Tom
Brady of Philip Rivers part are still
playing on an extremely high level you
know Alex last week listening to your
work in terms of listening to the
interviews you did with a bunch of the
players was there any why to anybody
that kind of stuck out you know a guy
that kind of really impressed you and
whether it's his interview skills or
just a guy that you for the first time
meeting you like wow I got a draft this
kid oh man you know that's that's a
danger right right fall in love with the
interview you know and you know so
listen I mean sometimes kids can talk
themselves out of something you know
what I mean but I mean but these young
men are trained I'll be honest they look
at you listen Dexter Williams you like
to know that he's in a good place in his
life right now the kid from Notre Dame
served a four-game suspension last year
on a marijuana related thing and then he
comes back and he's gangbusters for
Notre Dame 12 touchdowns you know his
mom has a terminal disease and she's
living with him and you'll pull for
people like that you know what I mean so
that that young man you feel for ie no
Eric McCoy the senator from Texas A&M
Wow you know you're talking about a
combination of having a great centers
body if you know what I mean very
compact and squat former a shotput guy
back in high school and you know he
ended in his ability to know he said
that his vision grew during his time at
Texas A&M as far as calling out
protections and things this is a plug
and play guy if your team needs a center
he's someone that that is really going
to impress you as well you know so but
you know it's sometimes it's interesting
though like how you know folks handle a
crowd like Ryan Mallett you could just
sort of tell that this young man might
have a real hard time in the NFL getting
defensive during an NFL Scouting Combine
interview in front of people you know km
Newton isn't the best for the media
though and he went ahead and ended up
having had a great NFL career so I don't
like to read into it too much but but
you find some young men along the way
that you really begin to pull for and I
got to tell you one of them I
interviewed on the phone is Cory
Valentine of Washburn oh my god
I mean you talk about a guy who clay it
at a small division to school largest
crowd he's ever played in front of his
15,000 people his mom had to convince
him to stay in college because he wanted
to quit he was living out a bunk bed
that was part of his his dorm life you
know look playing Division 2 football
but you know what the guy was able to
overcome all that he's the best small
school corner in football I don't think
he gets past a - I don't think it gets
passed around - to be quite honest with
you this young man has huge upside and
you talk to him for about two minutes
and you figure out not only does it
happen together on the field he's got it
together off as well he's Alex Marvin
SiriusXM NFL radio joining us here on
the Rich Eisen show Kirk Morrison
filling in for rich and I think Alex the
next question is obviously Alabama has a
ton of guys that we think can go in the
first round we look at this Clemson team
of this past season and a bunch of their
guys possibly going in the first round
one is Dexter Lawrence had a quad injury
I believe warming up for the 40 what's
going to happen
- Dexter Lawrence
ha what are they saying about that
injury is that gonna hurt him or help
them right before he goes uh for that
pro day well I mean laughs now now that
the pressure is gonna be on to compete
at the pro day right but you know Kirk
it's funny you bring that up because it
used to be like you had to have like
like Gil Brandt you know my Sirius XM
partner going in the Pro Football Hall
of Fame he's he's adamant he said I
would not draft a player unless I had a
40 time on it and when we say a 40 time
I need to I need to explain it's
actually a 10 20 and 40 right and what I
mean by that is the first 10 yards the
first 20 yards and then the completed 40
yard time because really the first two
are just as important if not more so
than that 40 time so you know overall so
I think that's that's how it is but we
saw some players get drafted last year
without really putting together a real
40 you know some of them just simply try
you know whether they said it was injury
a quad a hamstring a foot I'm not saying
that Dexter Lawrence you know is faking
anything this is a huge moment for him
the guys spent two months of his life
preparing to run or six weeks you know
preparing to run this 40-yard dash and
then you don't get to compete and it's
disappointing so it's just gonna put
more of an onus on him to compete at his
pro day and if he gets a poor time then
well you got to go back and look at the
film and that's what all of these
measurables all of this Olympic type
events that we're having here at the
combine I mean you need to look back and
say okay this guy ran this time how does
it correlate to football you know I mean
or this guy was a little bit slow but do
they make amends because they're so
smart that they can envision things
happening they do their homework in
their playbook and then they show up and
they make the play I mean so those are
the things you want to marry the numbers
that you have on the field with the type
of football player that you're going to
be getting and there is a difference
between the two I mean need I point out
that the third-fastest 40 time in the
history of the combine is a guy named
ray Archer from Kent State has a split
node in Pittsburgh Steelers a
third-round pick Curt they couldn't get
they couldn't teach him how to use the
speed to make people miss ed he got out
of the league really quick yeah that's
the one thing that obviously when you
look at the combine it's always a speed
speed and that's what catches everyone's
eye balls outside of it but you know
just kind of stick it on Dexter Lawrence
really quickly I mean here's a guy that
was suspended for a couple games didn't
play in the national championship in the
the semi final as well so when you
you have a guys like that who aren't
able to fully I guess participate in the
combine and then you have to go back to
the tape and you got to worry about the
off-the-field - how does that hurt his
chances well you know that whole PUD
thing is really weird right now you know
there were several Clemson players who'd
been suspended who tested positive I
think in his case all he can do is just
say look I didn't know what I was taking
I apologize and I'll take whatever drug
test you want at any time right I mean
that you throw yourself upon the mercy
of the court
you know we can go back to the Chargers
defensive lineman his name is escaping I
think it's Luis Castillo yes correct
yeah from you know northwesterly sent a
letter to all the teams saying I cheated
I took steroids and you know I'm sorry
you know what I won't do it again he
still got taken to the first round I'll
take place harder right so it didn't it
didn't hurt him in that case but yeah I
mean you know so that's why the draft is
such a gamble right and you know because
people wonder Oh trade back right it's
always the lazy media narrative or the
lazy fan there they've trade back
because I'd love to have two
second-round picks for my first but you
have to realize that the odds of getting
it right in the second round are far
less you know you're good for you than
it is if you draft in the first round
you know most teams and even though we
have 32 picks in round one there aren't
32 first-round caliber players in every
graph no usually there's about 17 or 18
and then he starts to get into tearing
TI e RI ng where it might be you have
guys from 18 to 20 to 45 that you all
have second round grades on it would be
beauty in the eye of the beholder of
where the teams are drafting the higher
you pick the greater your chances of
success this is how it works in the NFL
Draft
that's why players like Dexter Lawrence
sometimes they're boom or bust right if
you want to invest a high pick and a guy
that you just don't feel necessarily
comfortable with or you make a bad
talent assessment or there's more issues
that pop up later well then shame on you
right absolutely a couple more minutes
here with Alex Morpheus of Sirius XM NFL
radio you know Alex obviously the
LeBrons the shop was on the other night
on HBO and obviously we had some candid
words in terms of Antonio Brown talking
about his situation in Pittsburgh
Alex how is this going to play out
obviously
March 17th the Steelers have a decision
do they pay him that roster bonus so
what's going to happen what do you think
how does this thing in let's go back to
the 1970s before Antonio Brown was even
an apple in his parents eye okay and the
Pittsburgh Steelers have been known to
never blink when it comes to these types
of situations this is the team that
traded Franco Harris over a contract
dispute Franco ended his career in
Seattle they butted heads with so many
different people about pay and they have
never bent right this is how the
Steelers are so I go back who's there
are truly the second running the team he
knows what his grandfather did he knows
how his dad handled all this so now we
get into this game a chicken with
Antonio Brown right because for the
Pittsburgh Steelers they they control
although everything this isn't like lady
on Bell in terms of okay if Le'Veon
doesn't show up all they can do is hope
that he sides and Antonio Browns case if
he doesn't show up for training camp
they just start going after money they
start filing paperwork in court and they
may say listen this guy you know we paid
him this money he needs to show up
because this is this is part of the
rules of the collective bargaining
agreement but Antonio Brown I think is
trying to make himself up enough of a
nuisance that you know what he may even
in his mind be thinking I don't want to
be traded I want to be released
I mean I'm gonna I'm gonna say as much
obnoxious stuff as I can to try to get
the Pittsburgh Steelers to get rid of me
oh and if they want to pay me 2.5
million dollars to still be on the
roster by March 17 that is fine
but I want to be able to sign with my
own team and I want to be able to make
my own musa said it may be being shipped
off to a team where he doesn't want to
be I mean if you're an Tonio Brown do
you want to go to the Washington
Redskins
I mean Colt McCoy's your starting
quarterback right now how much does that
excite you you want to go out to the
Raiders I mean you know look you want
you want to have another losing season
you've never had one before so it's not
even another I mean think about that so
that's that's the thing so you just you
know listen every time I Antonio Brown
opens his mouth it hurts his trade stock
but does it hurt Antonio Brown as far as
the football player stock goes I don't
necessarily think it does I just think
he's trying to get his way out of
Pittsburgh and scorching as much earth
as he can so that the siller's you know
if they want to take a subpar deal
listen he burns them on the way out or
if the Steelers just say you know what
we're just tired of this and you cut
them and that's Antonio Brown
game here well he's definitely doing
enough to try to fuel that to try to get
his way out the door but again the
stiller is a very stubborn team I could
see this one lasted for awhile pitch
free doesn't get the type of offer that
they want yeah I can see this possibly
going all the way up to the draft
honestly remember last year they traded
martavis Bryant I during the draft I can
actually see that happening as well with
the Steelers but last question for you
Alex before I let you go I know you're
down in Florida as well so Nick Foles to
the Jaguars I know it's not for sure yet
until March 13th but what does that do
for Jacksonville to have John D philippa
offensive coordinator reunited you know
with Nick Bowles it gives them a shot to
get back to where they were in 2017 and
that's an AFC title game and I'm not
exaggerating here I mean look the Jags
have to have several things break right
for them they've got to avoid another
season of injuries the way that it hit
them in in 2018 they've got to find some
more juice at the wide receiver position
marquel Marquis Lee coming back will be
a big boost cuz he's not only a good
receiver he's also a really good blocker
they got to find something a tight end
as well and you got to make the defense
you know start to get those impact high
plays again they're a very good defense
last year they're just not great they
weren't doing the types of things that
you know affecting the quarterback that
they had in the past and you saw a
little bit of a dip from from Jalen
Ramsey for example you know in that
regard so but the talent is still there
on defense and I think Nick Foles being
that that galvanizing guy in the locker
room someone that has been there and
done that as one of Super Bowl as a
starting quarterback in his anxious to
show too I'm sure you know looked at
that he can leave his own team so the
promised land so to speak and working
with John D Filippo as quarterbacks
coach from the Eagles in an offense that
he's gonna know inside and out of having
Leonard fournette in the backfield
behind him and hopefully a happy Leonard
fournette hopefully ace in or at least
spelt Leonard fournette behind him in
the backfield working with his new
running backs coach Terry Verbitsky
there's a lot to like about the
Jacksonville Jaguars if they're able to
get this next fall's deal done don't
forget to follow him on twitter at Alex
Marvis hey Alex always appreciate the
time my brother no problem I wait a
second what is the race between you and
rich because he might be catching up on
so I guess you haven't visited my
Twitter lately because I posted a video
of I combine letting everybody know I
still have it so you can go check that
out
like 42 years ago yeah I did it on
national turf so I'm just letting people
know what it look like I'm a real
linebacker appreciated Alex always been
okay oh man that's how much more of a
serious XM NFL radio the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience